hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
The Walking Dead directly picked up
after that Big Bob WTF moment and look
pretty much like it was ripped right off
the comic book page if you haven't rid
of the comics the last two episodes were
pretty much right out of volume 11 fear
the hunters you should be able to buy
that on comiXology at a big discount if
you want to go back and see how it all
went down there were a few minor changes
that all explained also new round of the
giveaway starts right now so all you to
do dinner is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so careful if
you're not caught up on Walking Dead
starting with top five moments number
five tainted meat so this was the
conclusion of the big comic book scene
from last week Bob waking up realizing
the hunters that eaten his leg in the
comic it was Dale but everything else on
the show pretty much went down like it
did in the comics he starts laughing
hysterically and says you idiots I've
been bitten they all spit out the Bobby
Q and dump him on the lawn just to freak
everyone in the church out they did say
that they were gonna be doing a lot more
comic book moments this year so be on
the lookout for other big like WTF
things if you have been reading the
comics number four Gabriel explains his
backstory also went down pretty much the
way it went down in the comics he shut
his congregation out when the apocalypse
hit and was too scared to let them in
whenever the walkers came he had to
listen to them all be ripped apart even
the little children so he went a little
nuts things were getting pretty crazy
inside the group I mean obviously
Gabriel was the source of the tension
previously but now you have Sasha and
Abraham generally they kind of cool down
though it seemed like everyone pretty
much cooled off and they're not jamming
a gun down Gabriel's throat anymore not
that he's like their best friend yet I
did like his reaction to what they did
to the hunters later in the episode this
is a church I'd be interested to see if
being with the group starts to socialize
him a little bit more and he starts to
regain some of his humanity I don't
think he'll ever find Redemption I mean
it just doesn't seem like it's part of
his character that he's gonna forgive
himself but it is possible he could
martyring himself in some biblical way
if the opportunity ever presented itself
again since he's a comfortable character
it's possible that they could just play
that character out the way he is in the
comics number three Abraham vs. Rick
they started to tease some tension with
Abraham in the last episode with him
wanting to take off for DC in the group
not wanting to split up they did reach a
compromise but the interesting thing is
that that bus that they took off in in
the trailer is seen like flipping
through the air so clearly something
crazy
is going to be happening and since the
next week looks like a Beth episode we
might have to wait two weeks to find out
what's going on with that group just
like last year though it seems like
they're splitting storylines off it'll
just give us an opportunity to see more
places here's a good look at the map
that Abraham gave him that's essentially
the route to Washington DC because the
whole reason for them splitting up was
waiting for Daryl and Carol and Daryl's
back now I think we're gonna find out
where they're going next
obviously it's probably gonna have
something to do with Carol and Beth we
didn't see who was behind Daryl at the
end of the episode but I'm guessing that
it was not Carol otherwise she would
have just come right out like they
wouldn't have made us wait to find out
number two hunting the hunters
this was also a continuation of the fear
of the hunter storyline from the comics
Rick and the survivors trapped the
hunters using the church they turned
themselves into bait so Chris the leader
of the hunters walks in obviously on the
show it's Gareth
so the comic story goes in the slightly
different direction essentially ends the
same way though in the comics it was the
next morning before they'd away with
Chris on the show obviously Rick keeps
his promise and slices the hell out of
him definitely one of the best crazy
Rick moments like when he gets crazy
scary you can kind of tell that the rest
of the group is looking at him a little
bit differently after this even though
he tries to justify it you saw what they
were capable of essentially he's
becoming darker and darker
I think Judas is obviously his
counterbalance and they had that nice
moment with Bob at the end so it does
seem like Rick is hopeful and there was
a message on the map to the new world is
gonna need Rick Grimes so I think there
was a hopeful spin on his character
they've always been a lot of comparisons
between Rick and the governor like
they're very similar people the
government or just took it a little too
far
and my number one WTF moment Bob is dead
he was a marked man the minute he got
bit and didn't tell anyone
they might have been able to save him if
they had treated him right away there's
really no official timeline as to how
long it takes for someone who's bitten
to turn but if it's been more than 12
hours were you're pretty much guaranteed
dead and a lot of people were curious
about the tainted meat if the hunters
would have turned if they ate the meat
technically no I mean he would have been
a decayed person like you'd have to eat
one of those waterlogged Walker's in
order to turn him dying was a comic book
scene but obviously they had to change a
lot of things because they don't have
Andrea anymore
in the comics Andrea is the one that
killed Dale Dale obviously being the Bob
character in that version she shoots him
in the head after they declare their
love for each other and he dies on the
show Sasha had her knife but Tyreese
took it and he killed Bob for her I
think just as her big brother he was
just trying to preserve some of her
innocence like he didn't want her to go
to that place like she's still a
relatively innocent person not quite as
innocent as Beth although that might
change for her soon but she hasn't gone
to that crazy place that Tyreese has
been to that he's trying to stay away
from like not killing people it was a
total bummer moment and we're totally
gonna miss Bob but I think they gave his
character a really good send-off
everyone got to say their goodbyes even
some of them had their own scenes with
him like Rick and Sasha most characters
don't get that but I do really like when
Walking Dead kills one of the main
characters off they do it in a really
memorable way either really epic or
really poignant like with Bob they will
take care of you they might kill you off
but they will take care you Andrew J
West the guy that plays Gareth actually
revealed that Scott Gimple when he
called him to come on season 5 he said
full disclosure we're gonna kill you in
episode 3 I just think it's funny that
from behind the scenes standpoint you
know actors typically know what's gonna
go on if they're gonna be dying really
soon the full disclosure you know you
can say no if you want we're gonna kill
you at this moment I don't think that
anyone would say no to coming on Walking
Dead even if they knew they were gonna
die really soon there was a little bit
of confusion because people had been
reporting that Andrew J West had been up
to series regular and series regulars
usually appear in most if not all the
episodes so that might have just been
inaccurate either way next week
totally Beth episode we're obviously
gonna find out who's with Daryl - he'll
probably explain what went on with him
and Carol on their side trip
if anyone's had the chance to play it
there's actually a video game that might
reveal a little bit about what's going
on with the Noah character as well as
Beth it's called The Walking Dead
survival instinct it's said in the world
of the TV universe like it's not like
The Walking Dead telltale game it might
not necessarily be what happens on the
show but in the game Daryl goes to
Cleburne Memorial Hospital
we know Beth on the show is gonna be at
a hospital but the game description just
in the wiki reads you know when the
outbreak began government research crew
took residents at Cleburne Memorial
Hospital they had military protection
that kept it operational Daryl arrives
looking for antibiotics for Merle finds
Noah who was treated for a gunshot wound
later finds doctor searching for cure
experimenting on Noah as a test subject
and Daryl has to choose whether or not
to save Noah so Beth could be like the
Noah character in the game but that
still leaves the question about what's
going on with Carol and we haven't seen
the Noah character on the show yet the
Tyler James Williams character so lots
of big questions hopefully most of those
will get answered next week but it's
basically gonna be just like the
governor episode during season four
what'll be all about Beth it'll like
rewind in time to the time when she was
taken there have been leaked images from
the Beth episode so if you watch that
clip or you saw those images just please
use spoiler tags if you're gonna comment
on them below because most people
probably haven't seen him let me know
that what was your favorite moment from
the episode and what do you think
happened to Daryl and Carol when they
went to find Beth overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus it was a solid
adaptation of a comic book moment or
several comic book moments they gave
nice send offs to both Gareth and Bob I
really like the way they did their
endings obviously Gareth had to die in a
burly violent way you live by the sword
you die by the sword the Bob character
in general just had a really great arc
on the show I mean he was essentially a
bit of a douchebag during season four
recovering alcoholic who just kept
getting into trouble because of his
addiction then in the second half of the
season he turned his life around and
fell in love with Sasha obviously that
didn't work out even though he kind of
got himself in trouble in this episode
again like he got himself captured he is
at his core a good person
you will be miss Bob We will miss you
especially Sasha who's probably gonna
get really dark now there is no way
she's just gonna let go of that anchor
Tyrese is like the voice of reason in
the episode I was a little disappointed
in Sasha when she demanded that Tyreese
stay with him rather than
she do it there's a lot of people
hypothesizing that she might turn into
comic book Andrea
you can let me know whether or not you
agree with that but I do think that
Sasha is gonna toughen up a little bit
like she's gonna go slightly in a Karel
direction you can't replace Karel like
she's not gonna be Karel but she will
just get a little bit harder that's also
the big teaser for Beth - this is gonna
be like the season where she toughen up
evolve or die
overall I just I really love the
direction the show's gone this season
it's just been a nice twist I mean I
really enjoyed the second half of season
4 obviously the first half of season 4
not quite as exciting but you know we
did have the mid-season WTF there been
so many other rumors about which
characters might die this season though
I think it's a little early to speculate
but I do think that somebody else is
gonna die during the mid-season finale
so I will be posting a Q&A video for
this tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to
get it
leave all your questions and if you have
read the comics just remember to use
spoiler tags if you've read ahead lots
of other big stuff going on too Marvel
has like a big announcement they're
doing on Tuesday so I'll try to get some
bonus videos out for that too right now
you can actually click here to get that
Q&A video I have the annotation as soon
as I post it tomorrow and you can click
here for my episode - Bob PQ video thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high five and say one more goodbye to
Bob